Tenemos el sistema de ecuaciones "y" igual
a "4x" menos 17.5 y "y" más "2x" igual a 6.5
y tenemos que resolver
ese sistema para "x" y "y", es decir,
buscamos "x" y "y" que
cumplan ambas ecuaciones.
Para esto pensemos en lo siguiente,
en la ecuación de arriba, la "y" ya está despejada,
déjame reescribir esta ecuación,
lo voy a hacer en rosa.
"y" igual a "4x" menos 17.5,
así es que esta primera ecuación está
estableciendo la restricción
de que "y" tiene que ser igual a "4x" menos 17.5,
de acuerdo a la segunda ecuación
si al valor de "y" le sumamos "2x",
debemos de obtener 6.5.
La "y" de aquí tiene que cumplir la restricción
de la primera ecuación, tiene que cumplir
con la restricción de que debe ser igual
a 4 veces el valor de "x" menos 17.5,
lo que podemos hacer entonces es
sustituir el valor de "y" de esta primera ecuación
en la segunda ecuación.
Déjame precisar lo que voy a hacer, la secunda
ecuación es "y" más "2x" es igual a 6.5,
sabemos que "y" tiene que ser igual a esto
que tenemos aquí, "4x" menos 17.5,
tomemos entonces "4x" menos 17.5 y vamos a sustituir
este valor de "y" aquí, así es que si reemplazamos
esa "y" por "4x" menos 17.5
que es lo se establece en la primera ecuación,
obtenemos entonces
"4x" menos 17.5 más "2x" igual a 6.5.
Ahora ya tenemos una ecuación lineal en una
sola variable, vamos a despejar "x".
Tenemos aquí "4x" y "2x" que vamos a sumar
"4x" más "2x" nos da "6x" menos 17.5
y esto es igual a 6.5.
Ahora, vamos a deshacernos de este 17.5 sumando
17.5 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
sumamos 17.5 del lado izquierdo
y sumamos 17.5 del lado derecho,
¿qué tenemos entonces?
Tenemos que "6x" estos términos se van y
esto es igual a 6.5 más 17.5, veamos,
6 más 17 es 23 y .5 más .5 es 1, esto es igual
a 24, dividiendo ahora entre 6,
ambos lados de la ecuación, estos se cancelan
y nos queda que "x" es igual a 24 entre 6 = 4.
Ya hemos calculado del valor de "x" de la
pareja "x", "y", que cumple con estas ecuaciones,
vamos a calcular ahora el valor de "y",
podemos hacer esto al sustituir este valor de "x"
en alguna de las dos ecuaciones, en cualquiera
de las dos vamos a obtener el mismo valor.
Usemos esta de arriba, suponiendo que "x"
es igual a 4, entonces esta ecuación resulta en
"y" igual a 4 por el valor de "x" que hemos obtenido
que es 4 menos 17.5...
menos 17.5.
Esto es igual a 4 por 4 = 16 menos 17.5,
lo cual es igual a -1.5,
éste es el valor de "y".
Así, la solución a este sistema de ecuaciones
es "x" igual a 4, "y" igual a -1.5.
Esta solución funciona para las dos ecuaciones,
por supuesto en la de arriba,
4 por 4 es 16 menos 17.5
obtenemos el valor de "y" de -1.5,
también funciona para la ecuación de abajo,
chequemos esto,
tenemos que -1.5 más 2 veces
el valor de "x", más 2 por 4,
¿y esto cuánto nos da?
-1.5 más 8, esto es 6.5.
Así es que estos valores de "x" y "y"
cumplen con ambas ecuaciones.